loin de l'océan au cœur des milétants
ses jours de pêche à Maré
basse vidé de ses eau pour entretien l'
temps recellent de nombreuses espèces de
poissons gros petits c'est là un peu
plus loin sur la table de tri pas de
temps à perdre la bête aquatique
supporte mal le grand TER les gardons
ils peuvent mourir si on les trie pas
assez vite donc quand même se donner du
mal pour des étants et faire tout mourir
parce qu'à la table de tri on n pas été
assez rapide c'est un peu rageant donc
donc pour le coup faut quand même
accélérer la
cadence gardons tanch et brochet des
variétés apprécié en revanche d'autres
sont nuisibles à l'élevage on a des
poissons indésirables hein comme les
écriss les perches soleil ou les choses
comme ça et là ça permet de de
sélectionner pour remettre du brochet
par exemple éventuellement de cette
taille là et les gros brochets pour les
manger voilà c'est pour ça qu'on fait le
tri pour assaignir et régénérer le
milieu une vidange est conseillé tous
les 2 ans afin d'éviter l'envasement sur
les 1500 étang que compte le plateau
très peu sont entretenus cette
annéeexemple seul 20 é an du plateau
seront danger une vingtaine d'étant
c'est trop peu hein pendant ce tempsl on
a vous avez vu il a beau poisson chez
moi on va acheter du poisson en Hongrie
en Pologne parce qu'on produit pas assez
sur le territoire ce qui est désolant
c'est vraiment ol on a un potentiel
extraordinaire qu'on ne sait plus faire
vivre il faut absolument gérer les de
manière traditionnelle comme nos anciens
avec des vidanges régulière on maintient
une culture et un savoirfaire ça permet
de trans ce savoir indispensable à la
périté du plateau la pêche du jour
s'élève à une centaine de kilos une
partie sera vendue ou consommée le reste
du poisson attendra dans quelques
semaines le retour de l'eau dans les
temps